do you how about the picture I post the
list from fine kid 3d great
I remember hey my favorite is when these
[ __ ] morons DME go dude
quarantine really and you guys are doing
this Mike you [ __ ] idiots
this white you know ya thin out the herd
okay now hopefully it gonna thin out the
earth mixtures actually incredible my
makeup work is good I know we have real
deal people is so good that was the best
sketch we did in a way that acting
instead that was not one was good that
one was good and the one ride going for
the audition as the police officer oh my
god your horse though were so good not
remember that you were so girl fun that
was she was so good Matt those very good
acting dude very good acting because you
weren't acting no we never had all the
one with wills really good - oh we can't
kill him faster well how about the one
with you about when we kill your wife oh
yeah dude I like naked and afraid that's
a great one - they were all mean by word
but naked
we kind of should probably and Mitch was
a huge part of that ministry you well we
do have Mitch on board son hundred
percent
we have Mitch we have Marshall I know
we'd have D'Elia involved I I'm down
dude do you I'm down I tried to get us
all together and you just didn't want to
do it who didn't wanna do it you dude
I've been forcing you to do afraid my I
think Fox awesome right but I'm sure
they're all over [ __ ] we all have to see
them though no weed remember we played
in last time we gotta yeah so you can
buy them right can you still buy them I
think you still get it on a platform
called voodoo what happens if we kept
find the kids 3d what's that I mean we
saw them on Vimeo they're free on Vimeo
really yeah you can if you Google we can
find him but we can't play him on here
no cuz we got Flag last time I haven't
seen forever Oh remember when I need
life insurance because I might die oh my
god yeah and we went through the
speed-dating
yes and then you're like I got and
that's when he kill me try to find your
replacement there it is dude that was so
[ __ ] fun we were laughing so hard at
that I came with that shirt that's my
badass shirt yeah
sick yeah isn't that [ __ ] sick so if
you got finally kid 3d the VIP package
came with that shirt and all the series
and Brian special dude we we sold us
[ __ ] have you ever seen how many of
those we sold right so I was talking to
Lewis Jones mouth guy yo dude me a brown
one do a fine kids 3d part deuce and he
goes where a hundred percent on board
let me know what you guys want to do get
a one made remember this we should do it
it was so fun I think I feel like well
there right now is when we should write
it that's when we were all scared wow
that was fun man it was just fun - yeah
was and and the beat I'll go back chin
because I saw uh I'm alright this this
is another therapy don't go to the where
did I just see that at this long is on
venmo is that what you say it Vimeo
Vimeo Vimeo I saw it somewhere scroll
down mm-hmm oh there it is Mitch Rosen
venmo oh say no to drugs PSA the best
and if you click on that will take go to
jail I probably go to that Vimeo really
yeah see I think it's that whoever the
director was I think it's his uploads it
was 40 years ago well we can't play this
on no die just so you know even though
Mitch posted it yeah unless you can
contact him and see if Mitch's are not I
think we tried last time but something
that's way we did for old times they
explained for me in camera what am i
terrible this is the funny part where we
jump in the ocean have you seen these
guys yeah god damn dude I think that so
we did that in a day that's crazy
oh well none of them took long today and
we wrote me Mitch and Brennan wrote
all's we met at the pally house I think
we should I think we all said you know
what I think you know what I think we do
I'm being seriously I think you me and
Mitch sit down we just replicated so I
think we do eight of them fine but we're
writing but we just need this for you I
agree we sit down and start writing yeah
and we just and we just write eight and
I'm well let's do it let's do it we'll
do it zoom if Mitch doesn't wanna you
know whatever the case let's start doing
it we can do it from our own buggery two
hours a day we'd knock it out that was
so good and then we have maka to do it
all and we just cast out there's a big
we cast it with our buddies so you get
one we get one lead sponsor so it covers
the bills Wow we involve chin and cat a
hundred percent fun man hundred percent
he can act
you you've studied acting to write let
this go for theater dude come on
this would be sick sick I tried doing it
you're like yeah I think sketch is dead
no I'm a hundred percent down that's
sketchy dude no that's like that's great
stuff so funny that's crazy I used to
watch that in college when I first found
you guys I found you guys stream into
one of these clips yeah that's how I
started listening to the podcast I
wonder I think what you get a sketchy
I'll offer that oh yeah I do I wonder if
we can we I wonder cuz what if they talk
to who sells them that's great dr.
Feldman and talk to we stuck him it's
moot Justin
Carter Steve's moon about that one I
talk of Josh Lieberman two or three
words I know Josh really well me too
he's my man they were taken as he
watched it I see my thing is is we did
those like five years ago people like
you know Fox
kind of hoarded so be it get Josh Homme
please get Josh on this so since that
guy Mitch posted this on his Vimeo he
has the rights to do this I wonder if
you just went through him to see how you
can post these things I'm sure he knows
a little it's 13 minutes long did they
were amazing let me run down we did we
did and let me see the trailer disjoint
a minute let me see this one with the
dog the fake dog very good dude those
are funny very good all right it's a
bummer can't see them I know it's harder
to get 3d watch it right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]